Tyler is in Illinois thank you for your
guidance in Financial Peace University
regarding the different types of
insurance so one type of insurance I've
never heard you talk about that I'm
interested to hear what you have to say
about self defense insurance or
concealed carry insurance well I haven't
talked about it Tyler for two reasons
one is I don't have it personally I am a
firearms enthusiast I carry almost a
hundred percent of the time that you see
me at least where it's legal for me to
do so obviously if I'm in California or
New York I'm not able but otherwise if
you see me I'm just about always armed
the type of what I have personally done
and what I've done with our team here is
we've done extensive handgun training
active shooter training and how to
properly handle a firearm and basically
how to avoid ever having to use one like
run as an example the chances of me
being aggressive with the firearm are
almost zero after all the training that
we've had it will only be to save my
life or someone very near and dear to me
as life the chances of me doing
otherwise with a firearm is zero after
as much time as I've spent on this so
that's the way I've invested in
insurance so to speak that's not to say
you shouldn't do both possibly you could
do both the type of insurance you know
this falls under really what the
category of gimmick insurance and with
gimmick insurance oftentimes what you
get is the the idea of coverage but not
actual coverage now I've not read these
policies so there may be some that have
actual decent real coverage but
estimates are in the firearms community
that if you actually god forbid we're to
have to use your firearm and someone
were to lose their life even if they
were a criminal in the process of trying
to kill you it probably is gonna cost
you a million dollars
if you have it the in defense it's the
the process becomes just unbelievable
even if it's self-defense and so a
clear-cut so I you know I don't know if
that's accurate but that's what people
talk about in that community that it's
you know again as a deterrent to ever a
use of firearm if you can if there's any
possible way to avoid it so but in any
way the so if you are going to buy it I
would want to go into great detail about
what it does cover and what it does not
cover and then are you getting value for
that and are your likely scenarios
actually covered this falls under the
heading of stuff like extended
warranties and those kinds of things
that usually I have not have good
experience reading through the policies
again I've not read these particular
policies there may be some good ones out
there there's certainly going to be some
that are better than others but are any
of them worth it I don't know I don't
know meone and so that's you know that
that's why I haven't brought it up I
don't endorse stuff or tell people to
buy things that apply to my life that I
don't buy I don't tell you to buy
identity theft protection from Zander
insurance unless I bought it which I did
buy it from me every one of my kids and
every one of my employees 742 of them
and so it's um you know so I don't you
know I could speak very well into that I
do know that product line I do know what
the competitors are selling and I do
know that the center has the best
product on the market and to prove that
I bought it so you know that that's how
I do endorsements I don't need
advertising endorsement money badly
enough to endorse something that I don't
personally believe or use and so since
I've not dove into this there may be
some day they may bring me some proposal
and I'll learn about it and I'll do it
I'm not saying it's evil but it falls
under a heading of insurance that it's
not it's not drawn it's not caught my
eye and have
personally done it and that's not my
reasoning even though I am a firearms
enthusiast tonight I know that some of
you are very scared about that but you
know some of you live in areas of the
country or grew up in families or in
political affiliations or situations
where you for me of firearms more like
having a shovel in the garage it's it's
been in part of my life my whole life
and so I have no fear of that at all and
so it's just a simple you know it's like
driving my car to work to put my to put
my you know to mate to put my firearm on
in the morning I don't I don't think
anything about it
careful it's a it's obviously a
dangerous thing
and you have to be very careful with it
but some you don't understand then and I
understand that you don't understand but
um that doesn't mean I'm not gonna carry
one just because you don't understand so
it's okay and the rooms you show over
again well it's okay you can do that too
that's you know free country
because I because we're not really but
it's a great joke